no I remember but so jocelyn bell the
the lady who discovered pulsars never
got the nobel prize and she was here
talking to the students just a couple of
years ago she's now a very distinguished
scientist this she discovered pulsar
about 40 years ago and and anyway
students were asking her are you sorry
you didn't get the Nobel Prize and she
said oh no I've been all my life I've
just been famous for not having the
Nobel Prize and that was actually much
better and I think she's right I mean
you know it's much people asked why
didn't you get the prize it's much
better than if they're asking why did
you get it
oh I would say bringing up six kids and
who are all productive citizens